j
sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers
non tu n'es pas seul vous n'êtes pas
seul je suis là moi cool non mais ce que
je voulais dire c'est est ce que
l'humanité et seuls dans l'univers
est ce que notre terre est spécial et
unique
est ce qu'il y a de la vie
extraterrestre
je suis sûr que chacun d'entre vous
c'est poser ces questions en regardant
l'immensité d'un ciel étoilé
comment ne pas se sentir minuscule
devant cet infini sans signification
sommes-nous seuls dans toute cette
immensité
auparavant c'était des questions
philosophiques
maintenant nous essayons d'y répondre
d'une façon scientifique mais par où
doit-on commencer
et bien pas rechercher ce que l'on
connaît la seule vie que nous
connaissons et la vie sur terre
elle y est apparu il y a des milliards
d'années elle y a évolué et lee a
prospéré et partout sur terre on trouve
de l'eau liquide
on trouve de la vie nous avons donc qu'a
commencé par chercher d'autres planètes
comme la terre d'autres planètes qui
peuvent avoir de l'eau liquide à leur
surface mais ces planètes où va-t-on les
trouver allons les chercher autour
d'autres étoiles
ça s'appelle des exoplanètes
c'est-à-dire des planètes qui orbitent
autour d'autres étoiles que le soleil
quand j'étais petit je m'imaginais
trouver et explorer des mondes exotiques
de star wars et de star trek
c'est en partie ces images d'autres
mondes qui m'ont motivé à devenir
astrophysiciens mais on peut pas juste
prendre une photo d'une exoplanète
c'est vraiment un enjeu de les détecter
et n'imaginez pas quand on va regarder
dans un télescope avec nos yeux
alors comment est ce qu'on trouve cette
planète est bien en mesurant très
précisément la brillance de milliers des
toiles pendant des années et sans harek
le signal recherché est très faible
imaginez vous un instant sur un bateau
approchant la rochelle de nuit vous êtes
guidé par le phare à l'horizon tout
petit si vos yeux avaient la capacité de
nos instruments
vous pourriez voir l'atténuation de la
lumière du phare
quand un moustique passe devant et bien
une planète qui passe devant son étoile
ça fait à peu près la même chose et
c'est bien ces signaux de moustiques que
l'on veut chercher pour faire cela c'est
un travail de groupe
chacun a ses connaissances son expertise
spécial et c'est pas comme dans les
films
les grosses découvertes se font devant
un ordinateur c'est pas romantique mais
c'est ce qui nous donne accès aux
véritables zoos des exoplanètes
actuellement nous nous devons nous en
avons détecté plus d'un milliers et il y
en a de toutes les sortes
il y a des répits perso qui sont des
planètes comme jupiter mais très très
très très proches de leur étoile
il y a aussi des super terres et même
des méga terres qui sont des planètes
rocheuses jusqu'à vingt fois plus
massive que notre terre il ya toute une
diversité d'exoplanètes tout un
bestiaire est aussi tout un zoo de
systèmes d'exoplanètes
c'est un vrai bazar et nous sommes
totalement en droit de nous demander
finalement calé note
place quelle est la place de notre
système solaire dont tout ça tu as
raison on ne connaît que quelques
exemples d'autres systèmes qui ressemble
au nôtre
il est clair que le système solaire est
spéciale où au moins différente de la
moyenne mais on sait pas encore si le
système solaire et dans la minorité des
30% ou des 10% ou des 1% malgré le
nombre grandissant de planètes connues
nous n'avons toujours pas les capacités
de découvrir des vraies jumelles de la
terre et mais nous avons récemment
découvert une cousine de la terre elle
s'appelle kepler 186 m
vous voyez là moustiques qui passe
devant le phare en gardant la d'un peu
plus près nos collègues de la nasa nous
ont appelés un jour pour nous faire part
d'une découverte faite par le télescope
spatial kepler ensuite nous avons
utilisé quatre années de données et
travailler encore pendant huit mois pour
être sûr de la présence de cette planète
elle fait partie d'un système planétaire
avec cinq planètes les quatre planètes
les plus proches de l'étoile sont très
chaudes mais la cinquième la plus
éloignée et celles qui nous intéressent
kepler 186 f fait la même taille que la
terre à 10 % prennent et en plus elle se
situe à une distance de son étoile tels
que de l'eau liquide peut exister à sa
surface
c'est vraiment ça qu'on cherchait c'est
une planète qui me rappelle des images
d'autres mondes de mon enfance
nous n'avons pas les données
actuellement mais permettant non nous
d'imaginer nous pensons que la planète
est probablement rocheuse et peut avoir
des océans à sa surface
mais qu'est-ce qui serait différent si
on habitait sur cette planète
supposons pour l'instant que qu'elle est
comme la terre est bien le ciel ne
paraîtraient pas bleu mais rouge
et la planète serait entièrement
recouverte de nuages
c'est pas joli pour les images
d'artistes mais c'est ce qu'il faut pour
maintenir un climat habitable en fait ça
me dit j'aimerais bien aller explorer
cette planète attendent on n'en revient
c'est peut-être dangereux parce que
finalement on connaît pas grand chose de
cette planète et c'est ce qui fait aussi
que cette découverte est vraiment très
très très frustrante
on ne connaît que sa taille et sa
distance à son étoile mais on ne connaît
pas sa masse donc on ne peut pas savoir
de quoi elle est faite
et en plus on ne sait même pas si cette
planète à une atmosphère respirable
comme notre terre en fait on ne sait
même pas s'il ya de l'eau sur cette
planète
le fait d'être sur la bonne orbite pour
que l'eau soit liquide n'implique pas
forcément que la planète ait de l'eau on
a tous fait le cauchemar d'arriver à
l'école tout nu
on peut bien se trouver dans le bon
endroit mais avoir quelque chose qui
manque d'idées il est possible que notre
planète cousine soit complètement sèche
mais quand est ce qu'on va le savoir
ça va prendre du temps il va falloir
attendre la prochaine génération de
télescopes spatiaux
c'est comme ça les rafales de découverte
sont toujours suivis par de longues
périodes de réflexion des périodes
pendant lesquelles on ne peut
qu'imaginer nous savons maintenant que
notre terre n'est pas unique
nous avons trouvé une planète cousine
mais nous ne connaissons toujours pas
toute la famille des exoplanètes combien
d'autres planètes comme la nôtre existe
eh bien on pense que des planètes comme
la terre et aussi comme kepler 50.6 nous
des planètes qui peuvent avoir de l'eau
liquide à leur surface existe autour
d'environ 10% des étoiles
de notre galaxie or il y à 100 milliards
des toiles dans notre galaxie et
accrochez vous il y à 100 milliards de
galaxies dans notre univers alors vous
pouvez faire le calcul
mais ça doit faire beaucoup non
ok tu as dit 10% de 100 milliards c'est
beaucoup de zéros des toiles de 100
milliards de galaxies
oulala je confirme
ça fait beaucoup alors la prochaine fois
que vous allez regarder les étoiles que
vous serez allongé par terre ne voyant
que le ciel au dessus de vous quand vous
allez vous sentir
submergé par cette immensité rappelez
vous qu'au tour de beaucoup de ces
points lumineux
il y à d'autres monde et que rien ne
nous empêche d'imaginer que certains de
ces mondes soit habité
mais l'espace entre les étoiles est
immense ces autres mondes se situe à des
distances littéralement astronomiques
le système de notre planète cousine k
père 186e est située à 500 années
lumière de la terre
c'est à dire la lumière émise par cette
planète prend cinq cents ans à nous
arriver et nous si on voulait y aller là
bas on y mettrait des millions d'années
enfin nous sommes un peu isolés ici sur
terre
pour l'instant c'est notre seul foyer
notre seule maison prenant soin